foreign
so there is so much happening in the
world right now and our guest today
spends her days in fact her entire
illustrious career tracking and
Reporting on the moment's biggest
stories she is CNN's Chief International
anchor and host of the Network's
award-winning Flagship Global Affairs
program Amanpour on CNN International in
London and amanco on PBS in the United
States I'm so thrilled to have her here
with us to offer context on some of the
new stories that are impacting our world
and our lives and you can see her there
right now please welcome Christian
hello Christian how are you doing oh
Whitney thank you so much for having me
I'm so glad to be with you for a few
minutes and your Ted community on these
really important issues yeah and yes I
am the chief International anchor but
before that I was you know the the the
main International correspondent so all
my the way I work is always informed by
me being on the ground in the field and
having essentially walked the walk and
talk the talk with the people who are at
the coal phase I love that and I feel
like that's going to give us so much
perspective during this conversation
well so let's just dive right into it I
think one place we'd like to start with
is in Iran um so for those of you who
are on the call who haven't been
tracking back in September and Iranian
woman masamini died in the custody of
Iranian morality police after being
arrested for not wearing hijab on these
death uh sparked protests and a
revolution around women's rights in Iran
and beyond that is continuing into this
very moment and Christian I know that
you've reported um on Iran throughout
your career career
um and have spent a lot of time covering
this story very closely so how how
historically significant would you say
this moment is in Iran and could you
just give us some context on that look I
think it is very significant exactly how
and what will develop towards the end
I'm not sure
um a little bit of my own history I am
half Iranian and I grew up in Iran and I
spent essentially the first 20 years of
my life in Iran with a little bit of
going back and forth to the UK for
boarding school but that's where my home
was and that's where my parents lived
and my sister's uh essentially you know
I I was there during the build up to the
Islamic revolution of 1979 and so I saw
all that happening and that's what made
me want to be a journalist in fact to
tell those kinds of of History making
stories uh to the world and that's what
really focused me on the kind of career
that I then pursued fast forward now of
some 43 odd years and you can see that
the women who actually were pretty upset
at the beginning of the Revolution when
they had demonstrated for Khomeini
believing that he would bring democracy
as he promised uh back then to a country
that was a monarchy and then to quickly
find out that actually that wasn't his
plan and to quickly find out that he was
putting women under the veil which he
had not said you know earlier so for the
first year or so of the Revolution women
did not have to wear the veil and when
they did many many women came out and
demonstrated against it and then for the
decades since there's been a sort of a
kind of a tug of war between how how
strictly to put on the veil and not and
clearly differences between conservative
and religious women who want to wear the
whole tight covering uh that covers
their head very tightly covers their
body very Loosely known as a chardor in
Iran and then those who just didn't the
younger generation who felt well they
better you know follow the law but they
were kind of
treading their own path towards how they
would wear the hijab and you could see
coats and and body coverings were
getting Tighter and shorter head scarves
were getting more colorful and push
further back women and girls were were
going to Great Lengths to make
themselves look beautiful and stand out
as women they would do their hair
particularly the front of their hair
which stuck out of the of the scarf they
would you know bangs were not forbidden
um I I you know beautifully made up
their eyes their their you know their
their skin their lips were all just
beautifully done and Iranian women are
incredibly beautiful women in in spirit
and in and in body and that seemed to be
kind of okay
but what happened towards the last sort
of 10 years or so you've had a slightly
less Draconian regime when it comes to
enforcing hijab you know in the in the
late 90s early 2000s and then a much
more Draconian which is the latest one
so these very hard liners this Muller
you know Ibrahim raisi who is the very
hard line conservative president
actually came to the presidency by using
as his political platform among other
things a much tougher interpretation of
what they believe the you know the the
Islamic laws should be and of course who
paid the ultimate price women because
it's always whether it's in Iran whether
it's in Afghanistan whether it's in the
UAE or in Saudi Arabia or whether it's
in parts of Africa whether it's in the
United States
Etc women's bodies women's personal
space seem to be used
you know for people's political aims and
and so same happened in Iran and this
poor poor woman uh Masa amini at the age
of 22 came with her family from Kurdish
region of Iran to visit relatives and
was wearing a scarf and was wearing a
body covering but the police on the
corner at that time didn't think it was
conservative enough and that's why
there's a backlash
well you know in recent days a story was
circulating that some 15 000 protesters
were to be executed um and the veracity
of the story has been challenged and
disproven as I understand it it's
actually more like 15 000 protesters
have been detained and the Parliament
voted in support of the death penalty
for protesters but it's not um
ultimately up to up to them so I'm
curious um how real you think the
possibility is that something like a
mass execution might actually happen in
the near future how reliable threat is
that
well you're right that this story was
chased down including by us and it
turned out not to be as it was being as
it was being broadcast on the other hand
there are many many and you know
hundreds if not thousands of people
who've been rounded up and put into
prison whether they are women men young
girls other young people uh I I recall
hearing one of the top government
officials saying several weeks ago that
the average age of those who are being
arrested this is an actual government
government government official there the
average age was 15 and 16. and that's I
mean just think about it for a moment I
mean that's just unheard of anywhere
that children young girls people so
young are in the front lines of this
protest this Uprising this movement and
are being punished and then the latest
stories particularly by my colleague
fanos facie of the New York Times who's
incredibly good reporter has brought out
I mean some of the most terrible stories
of how young people are being dealt with
in a very harsh way and you know there
was uh over the weekend there was the
burial of a young boy 10 or 9 years old
who was you know a victim of all of this
and he he he he he was killed and his
funeral happened there was another big
protest there and you know these things
are defined normal Behavior Uh and even
for you know an Islamic Republic that's
been pretty Draconian for the last 43
years and this goes Way Beyond you know
riot control or whatever you might want
to call it so the question again is
because I know those outside of Iran
want to know is this the beginning of
the end or is this the end of the
beginning or is this the end of the
Islamic Republic and I'm just not ready
to say one way or another because you
just don't know
to what lengths they will finally go to
crush it and so I'm waiting as a
journalist should I'm watching I'm
waiting I'm interviewing I'm getting as
much information as I possibly can uh
and I'm going to be doing it on my show
today which will as you said on cnni and
on PBS and I've done it many times with
many Iranian interlocutors and um
this is a very brutal regime when it
comes to staying in power but the only
thing that I think is is is interesting
well there are many things that are
interesting but what's somewhat
different to before is that within the
Islamic establishment you have
voices actually male voices who are
questioning why they need to react this
hard against girls just for the hijab
and the headscarf so I will wait to see
where that where that conversation gets
to it if at all
and as someone was such a close personal
connection to Iran part of um your
heritage um and then also
um just your close reporting of this
story what do you feel are the things
that most of the world is is missing or
not seeing about what's happening there
well look I think in general foreign
policy and and stories from around the
world are hard to get past the American
public because they're hard to get past
our own editors so if there was more
reporting on a more regular basis of
these kinds of stories we would have a
much better and you all would have a
much better idea of trends of of of
what's actually happening
um you know in important forget Iran is
a very important country to the United
States and to the rest of the world
um partly because of the uh the the sort
of upheaval that the Islamic Republic
and including backing terrorism and and
Etc have caused to the world I'm holding
hostages as they continue to do uh
America Iranian Americans British
Iranians and a whole load of others who
are in jail used as political pawns and
this is this is you know a very very
unfortunate and and tragic situation
where human beings are being used as
political weapons so they're weaponizing
people who just happen to be half
Iranian or they've they've left and they
have become you know they've taken on
the nationality of of the countries that
have given them uh refuge and and when
they go back to visit family or person
on personal visits they have been
dragged into this political uh political
turmoil
so that's really bad and many
governments are having to deal with that
the other issue of why it's important is
because of the Iran nuclear deal now I
think that's off the table for the
moment it was always going to be off the
table pending the midterms but now
pending you know this this crushing of
this movement uh the US has imposed more
sanctions Europe has imposed more
sanctions on individuals uh who are
deemed responsible for the harshest
Crackdown so
it's very important Iran remains a very
very important country to the world and
don't forget you know it has a huge
population and such a huge majority of
the Iranian population are under the age
of 30 or or you know they're in that
Young Generation which means they're
incredibly well educated they are well
connected to the world even now even
though the regime is trying to cut them
off from the west and cut the world off
from them uh they manage uh you know to
play a very sophisticated technical game
of cat and mouse to get their stories
out and to get information from the
world in so you can never cut the
Iranian people off and they would
benefit and I hope they are benefiting
from the support that they know the
moral support that the world is giving
them on the other hand I know there are
others who call for more support to
overthrow the regime that's not my space
because I'm a reporter and I report on
what's going on there and I personally
don't believe that anybody any foreign
government is going to do that and I
also believe that the women and men the
male allies inside Iran
this is their movement this is their
movement they they don't want it to be
solid
um by any interference from abroad that
could get them even more tarnished than
the regime is trying to do at the moment
well Christian we're getting a lot of
questions from our members and I'm going
to actually start to bring some into our
conversation
um we have one from 10 member Dawn which
sort of speaks to what you're suggesting
around this idea of global support
um they want to know how can we help
from afar I feel helpless but would like
to do what I can without putting more
women In Harm's ways or Dawn shares well
it's very hard I mean definitely moral
support definitely spreading the word
spreading the word and supporting the
Iranian women in whatever way you can
some people ask how can we send them
material support whether it's money or
whatever it might be but that's very
very difficult and I do not have an
answer for that it's difficult because
Iran is so heavily sanctioned so it's
quite often illegal actually you know by
American law or european law or others
to actually send money to Via various
ways as far as I know maybe there are
ways that it's possible but I I don't
know those ways but it is quite
difficult to provide at the moment more
than material support I would say I do
believe the world should be a lot more
generous to those who are trying to flee
this and any other kind of repressive
regime right now I'm in London and as
you know over the last several certainly
months there's been a crisis in the
English Channel and a huge number of you
Iranians are trying to get you know away
from the from the danger zones and into
the UK
um a huge number of Afghans and you know
potentially others fleeing Wars and
devastation
but they get turned back and I think the
world's uh Asylum and Refugee policies
have become so Draconian and have gone
so far from being what they were
envisaged as to welcome those who are
fleeing a you know terrible oppression
and of course often starvation and
disease
um you know in in natural disasters and
the like
um and I think that's a real shame that
that we're seeing in this in this time
of Maximum upheaval in these parts of
the world the rest of the world actually
closing their doors and I've just I'm
about to do some interviews around a new
film that's coming out called the
swimmers and just to say it's about you
know two Syrian girls who had to leave
Syria at the height of the Arab Spring
and at during the Iran supported
Crackdown by the Syrian regime on those
who are demanding Freedom uh anyway they
managed to get out but they had to take
a rickety boat to get to Europe they had
to walk for Miles then they had to wait
for months you know for Asylum you know
people like you and me were dying in the
Mediterranean they're dying in the
English Channel they're dying you know
coming across from from Africa this is
2022 it's a scandal and I do believe
that that lack of of of Asylum that lack
of of Refuge is is a terrible shame and
a blot on all of us who who believe in
human rights and democracy and the value
of of life
well I want to move to another part of
the world
um also experiencing a huge crisis um
where you've been spending a lot of time
both reporting and actually physically
being there we know you just returned
from Ukraine um and we're now more than
nine months uh into the into the war
there uh so could you tell us a little
bit about your trip and and what um what
you saw as the people there are heading
into the winter and what would you like
for us to know about what you saw there
well because you just said winter I
think it's really important to know that
what Putin is doing now because he's
been thwarted on the battlefield is he
is literally taking this war to
civilians in a much more targeted and
devastating way than than he has been
already which has already been attacking
civilians but this Relentless attack by
cruise missiles and other really really
powerful including Iranian supplied
Kamikaze drones this is the civilian
energy infrastructure on a regular basis
uh it's some sometimes attacking
civilian residential buildings and
ordinary people are being killed and
wounded at the same time what turned out
to be a phenomenally resourceful
Ukrainian population whether civilians
or experts let's just take now the
engineers in the energy sector are
working around the clock day and night
to try to put this you know back and
they've done managed role rolling
blackouts and the like to try to make
sure that they can save some of the
energy infrastructure and particularly
let's not forget how tightly intertwined
is electricity and water those two are
Yin and Yang you can't really have you
know water without electricity to pump
it and so if you if you lack water fresh
water just to drink you're in real big
trouble and so the Ukrainian Engineers
are working around the clock to try to
make sure that people have at least at
least even if it's rationed
um access so that's a big issue I would
say I've been completely and utterly
overwhelmed and and and and and and
surprise not surprised delighted by the
spirit of the Ukrainian people you know
I've I've covered a lot of wars in which
much more powerful heavily armed
aggressors try to subjugate and force a
less heavily armed civilian population
into surrender and the ukrainians are
nowhere near that they have so much
heart they have so much love for their
country they have so much respect as the
Iranians do for the idea of
Independence sovereignty and personal
freedom and political freedom and
democracy that's what they're fighting
for and frankly they are our front line
troops the Ukrainian people right now
and to an extent the Iranian people are
our Frontline troops in Ukraine people
are standing between freedom and
totalitarianism and if Putin succeeds in
Ukraine then he's
I mean not only do the brave Ukrainian
people lose but then he comes a country
closer to the west and continues to
threaten
um the ideas and the values and
principles of democracy and freedom and
this idea that it was NATO's fault and
NATO expansion I promise you that it's
fake news I it's too difficult right now
to go into it because you don't we only
have limited time but it's not bad it's
the Putin does not want to see a free
and independent and Democratic country
in this case Ukraine on his borders and
then be asked why he can't have that why
his people can't have that he doesn't
want that he wants to create his own
sort of Greater Russia I witnessed that
covering Bosnia where the serbs backed
by Russia wanted to create a greater
Serbia on the backs of the Bosnian
people and in in Iran too and you've
seen the Afghan women and girls now
saying if Iranians can stand up and
demand their rights it's our turn next
so these have huge roll-on effects
effects and inspiration to people who
believe in basic Freedom dignity and the
right to to live their lives
well I know while you were there you sat
down with um Ukrainian President
Vladimir zielinski and first lady Elena
zelinska
um and I'm just curious what your
thoughts were about their mindset at
this point in the war and how you think
that will impact their leadership
well I think their leadership has been
extraordinary I mean really who would
have thought it this this this this man
below to me asylenski came from the
entertainment space he ran uh based on a
program that he had been he had been
starring in a series a TV series based
on corruption at the highest level and
so he ran as a clean candidate and and
then when he came into office that's
what he tried to bring in uh to to
increase infrastructure and to improve
it and to crack down on corruption
because Ukraine did have uh and may
still after the war have a corruption
problem but believe me now that is right
on the back burner and U.S senators of
both parties have told me that
everything that the Americans are
sending and NATO is sending is is
accounted for and they are not worried
about it going into somebody's pocket
unlike in Russia where it's gone into
obviously people's pockets because they
have barely a military machine that can
operate in in Ukraine much less against
NATO
um uh their leadership has been
inspirational the fact that the
president did not leave when he could
have done he did not take his wife and
children out when he could have done
um and and and the fact that they keep
quote unquote poking the bear and I
asked him that I said you know a lot of
people in the west are worried and and
elsewhere are worried that if you push
Putin too much you quote unquote put him
in a corner and he might do the
unthinkable and he said you know what
we've lived in this neighborhood forever
if we're not scared you shouldn't be
scared and I and I and I and I was
saying this because not only are they
pushing him militarily back but also if
you look at the Ukrainian defense
Ministry or or any of the online space
they're constantly trolling Putin
constantly and is done with Incredible
humor and and it's very very effective
and so they know something that we don't
know and as olena zelenska told me this
is our last stand this is it if we don't
stand up now there is no other time when
we can stand up if we don't do it now
when are we ever going to be able to do
it so they're very very clear about that
as you know there's been some talk
around the world some talk in the US in
Europe uh elsewhere that maybe you know
particularly after the liberation of
poisson by the ukrainians shouldn't the
ukrainians sit down at the negotiating
table so I asked president zelenski that
and he said look
we're happy to negotiate but based on
International principles based on the
Russians removing their troops from
there illegally invaded annexed and
claimed territory you know they've and
Sham referendums and Sham annexation and
by the way we're pushing them back so
they don't want to be pushed to a
negotiation while they have the upper
hand and one that would reward Russia
for its aggression and to be honest with
you we don't want that either we do not
want Russia to get away with today what
they did get away with in their first
invasion of 2014 when the world did not
stand up and did not uh challenge him
and this is what we're this is the
result he thought the world was weak and
that's his big surprise he was not he
was very surprised
um that a the ukrainians would stand up
be the West and NATO would stand up and
see that this Unity would last this long
and you know I come to it from you know
having covered something similar in
Bosnia for four years this was an ethnic
cleansing which they're trying to do in
Ukraine the Russians along the east and
it was a genocide which I believe that
um maybe not genocide but crimes against
humanity will be placed legitimately at
the feet of Russia after after this war
well in in both Iran and Russia thinking
about Ukraine we see a suppression of
speech and access to information how can
we know that we're receiving accurate
updates on what's happening in both of
these spaces well I do think you and
everybody have to take on a certain
sense of responsibility because that is
the challenge of our time you know
people ask me where do we find the truth
and I'm like well you can watch CNN you
can watch PBS you can watch BBC you can
read The Wall Street Journal or the New
York Times or the LA Times or or any
number of Financial Times wherever there
are many many organizations who are
committed to the truth and who have
reporters on the ground including in
Russia the BBC for instance has a very
very accomplished and good reporter
called Steve Rosenberg I highly
recommend you all to to access his
reports because under the constraints
that Russia has put on journalists he is
managing to tell the story in a very
very clever way right and also I would
you know just look at the Russian
State media Russian blogs and this and
that including the military bloggers who
are traveling with Russian troops in
Ukraine there's a huge amount of
information coming out that actually
Paints the accurate picture and right
now they're very which is not to say
they're they want the war to end but
they're actually painting the story that
the Russians are doing badly uh in in
Ukraine so there are there are places
and avenues to go but I believe that
it's really up to the consumer now we we
can do as much as we can to bring you
the truth fact check evidence-based news
information but you must not go to the
fake news sites and and believe that
that's the truth you must go to what I
would call the the news organizations
that have earned the Good Housekeeping
seal of authenticity and truth and uh
you know approval
it's really on you all now to to search
for those and that it's not hard they
exist
well and as we uh get close to the end
of our time here I just sort of want to
turn things to you Christian and and
your thinking as a a reporter a
journalist
um how would you say reporting on
conflict and crisis has changed the way
you think about the world your
perspective on life
I I think uh it's it's changed my
perspective in that I'm very clear that
I can't be a both siderism or a one on
the one hand on the other ISM in other
words in certain instances such as uh
gross violations of international
humanitarian law which we're witnessing
in other words you know human human
rights atrocities uh crimes against
humanity genocide and the like
um you you absolutely have to know where
the truth is and what you're looking at
so you know that they're aggressors and
there are victims there's no two ways
about that so my Mantra is and has been
and I've developed that from Bosnia
which was one of my earliest
um experiences in the field my Mantra is
truthful not neutral which doesn't mean
to say I'm not being objective I am
being objective because objective is our
Golden Rule and by that I mean you have
to look at all sides of the story and
report all sides of the story but what
you mustn't do is create any false
equivalence either factually or morally
and when you do do that you are actually
being untruthful and in some cases
you're being an accessory to terrible
atrocities and I would say the same
about climate I mean you can you can
talk about any of these crises these
moral and existential crises that we
that we find you know climate has been
too long for decades being treated as a
both scientism that the deniers had
equal factual uh or moral weight as the
science and it's just as we know not
true and so much time has been wasted to
the point that we are on the brink of a
global catastrophe and that is that is
something that I that I've learned that
in order to be a trustworthy credible
journalist I must must call out the
truth
well as we end here I want to end with a
question from a member which is
basically
um if you were to interview yourself
what would be the last question you
would ask so here's your last question
is what is what is your last question
for Christiane Oh Lordy my last question
I I don't know but I do know one thing
that I wish that I would be able to I
guess it would be how can you get more
access to
the other side you know I want to say
the Bad actors because they are how do
you get more access to them you know I
would like to sit down with a Putin or
Kim Jong-un or uh whoever uh Victor
Orban in Hungary or whoever's denying
democracy in the United States and and
and and the like I would like to sit and
talk to them to try to understand
not because I I think that I would be
you know I would suddenly become a
neutral Observer but because I want them
to spell it out so the people can see
and I would question them rigorously
that they're um would see the bankruptcy
of their positions and I would like to
keep doing that with fossil fuel uh you
know Executives and the like I've done a
few uh and with governments you know who
have allowed
um
politics politics to to endanger us all
I do believe those people need to be
held accountable so I would like to be
able to uh ask those people more
questions
well Christian thank you so much for
taking the time to chat with us today I
think it's used for everyone
um just appreciating
um everything that you've shared and
um good luck with the rest of your day
thank you very very much I appreciate it
it was good to talk to you all thanks
Whitney
[Music]